Donc comme je vous ai dit, on a fait un petit détour par rapport à nos études sur Galate.
On était en train de considérer les fruits de l'esprit.
Donc c'était arrêté dans la considération de la joie de l'esprit, une caractéristique chrétienne.
Un chrétien en tristesse, c'est une contradiction.
C'est très intéressant de remarquer l'importance de la joie comme un fruit authentique qui doit être constant dans la vie d'un chrétien.
Et si notre vie est plus marquée par la détresse et la tristesse qu'est la joie,
on est en train de vivre une espèce d'aberration dans notre foi.
On n'est pas en train d'harmoniser notre vie avec la constance de l'évangile.
Et l'une des principales raisons pour lesquelles un chrétien tombe dans la tristesse,
c'est car il perd de vue.
C'est de quoi se nourrit sa nouvelle nature.
Avec notre nouvelle nature, nous avons reçu de la part des dieux un nouveau palais,
la capacité de se réjouir des choses saintes, de l'évangile,
de la communion intime avec Dieu et du progrès et son Église,
du service, de la piété et la conformité de nos vies
avec ce qui fait la joie de Dieu lui-même,
ce qui fait la joie du Christ et de la manière dont Christ a vécu.
Et ce qu'on est en train de considérer, c'est que quand on considère la lettre aux Philippiens,
qui a appelé la lettre de la joie, nous apprenons par là que nous sommes devant un document historique
qui atteste sur la réalité, non seulement sur la possibilité, mais sur la réalité,
du fait que la joie chrétienne en toutes circonstances est saisissable.
L'apôtre Paul est en train d'exhorter les Églises à être dans la joie.
Il insiste sur cette exhortation,
« Réjouissez-vous » tout en étant lui-même emprisonné, battu, frappé,
en pleine misère selon les paramètres terrestres, humains.
Mais même là, lui-même, il présente quelle est sa source suprême des joies
et il exhorte sur cette base, cette Église à se réjouir.
Et il démontre que même dans la prison,
il peut non seulement se réjouir de ses solides fondements,
qu'il y a Christ,
et l'espérance inébranlable du retour du Christ
et de sa projection envers la gloire céleste.
Donc même s'il est proche de la mort,
il sait que son corps sera glorifié.
Même s'il est en train de vivre toutes les privations,
il sait que bientôt il va réjouir de cet univers glorifié avec le Christ.
Il n'y aura rien qui manque pour lui,
mais surtout, la chose qui fera sa joie principale dans les mondes à venir,
c'est la chose à laquelle il a déjà accès,
même dans la prison,
c'est l'intimité avec Christ,
c'est de compter avec la présence des dieux avec lui.
Et donc par là, l'apôtre Paul est en train de nous démontrer et d'éprouver
que tout comme en prison, en pleine privation,
il peut réjouir de la progression dans la connaissance du Christ intellectuelle
par les lectures dont il dit à Timothée,
« Amène-moi des livres et surtout les parchemens, la Bible elle-même »,
mais aussi la connaissance expérimentale,
car il dit dans ses passages,
« J'ai appris à être content en toutes circonstances ».
Les secrets, c'est de progresser non seulement dans la connaissance du Christ,
ce qui nous présente en Philippiens chapitre 3,
mais de progresser aussi dans la conformité avec ses souffrances,
ce qui fait une connaissance expérimentale du Christ
et de par là contribuer au progrès de l'Évangile.
Et donc, dans la lettre des Philippiens,
nous avons la présentation de la source suprême des joies chrétiennes
et aussi, attention, du fondement solide
pour toutes les autres joies périphériques, secondaires chrétiennes.
Cette source suprême des joies,
elle est Seigneur Jésus-Christ lui-même
et l'espérance inébranlable du monde à venir
avec un corps glorifié.
Mais c'est aussi le fondement de toutes les joies
qu'en Christ nous retrouvons.
Et voilà pourquoi Paul, il nous propose,
à partir du chapitre 4,
non seulement de nous réjouir toujours dans les Seigneurs,
mais de nous réjouir,
peu importe quelles soient nos circonstances dans ces pèlerinages,
dans plusieurs autres sources de joies
que nous pouvons encore réjouir dans cette vie.
Et donc au chapitre 4, il devient plus pratique
dans la démonstration d'autres sources de joies chrétiennes
qu'on a déjà considérées,
quelques-unes, on a déjà considérées trois,
et nous allons considérer une quatrième aujourd'hui.
Donc dans les Seigneurs qui est notre source suprême des joies,
et dans les Seigneurs qui est le fondement de toute autre joie
qu'on puisse avoir,
pendant notre pèlerinage,
nous avons aussi pour source des joies
l'amour fraternel approfondi par les services dans les Seigneurs,
donc l'importance d'une vie de relations significatives
au sein de l'Église locale,
avec des liens qui s'approfondissent
par les services en commun
et par la manifestation mutuelle d'amour
et par les plaisirs qu'on prend
dans la contemplation et dans la participation
du progrès dans la foi de nos frères et sœurs,
de voir la maturité de nos Églises pousser
et de surmonter,
ce n'est pas une Église parfaite,
mais de surmonter même les divisions
qui peuvent avoir lieu au sein de l'Église.
Donc c'est ce qu'on a considéré
entre les versets 1 à 5,
l'amour fraternel approfondi par les services
dans les Seigneurs
et qui surmonte même les divisions
envers la réconciliation.
Ensuite, la prière communautaire
qui rénouvelle la paix dans les Seigneurs.
C'est une autre source des joies,
les versets 6 et 7.
Donc, quelqu'un a déjà dit
la joie est la paix qui dansent
et on voit au verset 7
la paix des dieux qui surpasse toute intelligence,
qui peut être expérimentée
à n'importe quelle circonstance,
à partir du moment
où nous sommes persévérants
à présenter devant Dieu
nos désirs, nos besoins
par la prière et par la prière communautaire.
Et donc là, par la prière,
la paix des dieux va nous saisir.
Mais c'est intéressant,
on a considéré
dans notre dernier message sur ces textes,
dans les versets 8 et 9,
qui est par la sanctification,
nous pouvons réjouir de l'intimité avec Dieu.
Donc, verset 8, il dit
« Au reste, frère,
que tout ce qui est vrai,
tout ce qui est honorable,
tout ce qui est juste,
tout ce qui est pur,
tout ce qui est aimable,
tout ce qui mérite l'approbation,
qui est vertueux,
est digne de loin,
soit l'objet de vos pensées,
ce qui vous apprit,
reçu et entendu de moi
et ce qui vous avez vu en moi,
pratiquez-le
et les dieux de la paix
sera avec nous. »
Donc, attention,
par la prière,
la paix des dieux,
par la sanctification,
les dieux de la paix.
Les dieux de la paix
avec nous.
C'est la plus grande bénédiction
qu'on peut expérimenter
et il y a clairement dans la Bible
une proportion
entre une connaissance expérimentale
et intime des dieux
et la progression
en sanctification du chrétien.
Les purs des cœurs
verront Dieu.
Et ici,
c'est non seulement
la sanctification
qu'on puisse considérer
dans la pratique,
au contraire,
la pratique externe
de la sanctification
est un fruit
quelque part naturel
d'avoir occupé
nos résolutions,
notre pensée,
notre contemplation
du Christ
qui est l'objet suprême
de la contemplation
des sanctifications
et de l'admiration
des vertus bibliques
qui résument la piété.
Donc,
c'est,
comme je vous ai dit,
de ne jamais considérer
une voie
comme existante
pour nous
en tant que chrétiens
si ce n'est pas une voie
que Dieu aurait tressée,
que Christ aurait marché.
Donc,
la réalité,
c'est une résolution,
c'est d'occuper nos pensées
avec des réflexions
qui nous conduisent
à nous déterminer
à marcher
d'une manière sainte
en prenant en considération
les faits
que nous serons
non seulement rédévables
devant les modèles suprêmes
qu'il y a Christ,
mais rédévables aussi
si nous avons eu
les privilèges
d'avoir pour ministre,
pour guide spirituel,
des hommes
qui ont vécu
une vie scipieuse
comme celle de l'apôtre Paul.
Ce que vous avez appris
des mois,
reçu,
entendu des mois,
ce que vous avez vu en moi,
pratiquez-le.
Donc,
cette pratique est importante
de plus en plus
lorsque nous avons
des modèles
et des repères
de sanctification.
Et donc,
là,
c'est une source
de joie inébranable
car un chrétien
ne trouvera jamais
la joie
s'il ne progresse
pas en sanctification.
La joie,
pour nous,
les chrétiens,
est toujours
une conséquence
de notre sanctification
et pas l'inverse.
Et donc,
la joie n'est pas
encouragée
à être cherchée
directement.
La sainteté
est l'exhortation biblique.
À l'enfer,
avec nos sentiments
qui nous disent
qu'on aurait préféré
ou on a ressenti
de faire d'autres choses
dans la désobéissance
des dieux,
nous devons chercher
la sainteté
et nous allons constater
la joie qui viendra.
Et donc,
on va considérer
aujourd'hui
une autre voie
de joie
dans les seigneurs.
Pendant notre pèlerinage,
nous avons pour souci
des joies
dont les seigneurs aussi
les soins affectueux
envers les ministres
de l'évangile
ou une reconnaissance
généreuse
envers les ministres
de l'évangile.
C'est ce qu'on va retrouver
entre les versets
10 et 19.
Et avant de rentrer
ou nous plonger
dans ces passages,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer aussi
comment la providence
agit entre nous.
Donc,
non seulement
de la retraite
qui a lié
ces thèmes
au thème
des Galates,
mais nous allons
avoir aujourd'hui
même une AG
dont on va traiter
en des thèmes
qui est lié
aussi à ces passages.
J'étais censé
plutôt apprécier
ces sermons
la semaine dernière.
J'ai eu des empêchements
comme vous avez su,
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment ça peut
bien nous préparer
et nous équiper
à prendre
des bonnes décisions
dans notre AG
selon les critères
bibliques
qui nous trouvons
ici
et qui nous montrent
clairement
l'importance
de la responsabilité
d'une église locale
et même
de plusieurs églises
locales
dans les soutiens
d'un ministre.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
comment les langages
de la joie
reviennent
sur ces passages
et c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
un éloge
à la prédication textuelle.
Qu'est-ce que je veux dire
par là ?
Donc,
vous pouvez attester
depuis toutes ces années
des ministères d'enseignement
dans cette église
que nous avons traversé
des livres entiers
de la parole de Dieu
et ça fait
que la Bible
ne devienne pas
un otage
des préférences
personnelles
du prédicateur
qui cherche
à échapper,
à éviter
des textes
qui puissent
les confronter
mais il y a aussi
un aspect,
donc tous les aspects
sont positifs
mais il y a aussi
l'aspect positif
vis-à-vis
à l'avis du pasteur
où des fois
s'il fait le choix
de lui-même
de traiter certains textes
ça peut sonner
comme s'il était
en train de plaider
à sa propre cause
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
on va traiter
quelque chose
qui est profondément
nécessaire
pour l'enseignement
de l'église
ce sont les paroles
inspirées des dieux
ça fait partie
du Nouveau Testament
et ce sont des critères
par rapport à la considération
de comment traiter
ou soigner
les ministres
et c'est notamment
aussi quelque chose
de très pertinent
particulièrement
pour notre génération
et surtout
dans certains contextes
où
à cause
de plusieurs
scandales
d'abus
financiers
liés
à la rémunération
pastorale
parfois sans aucune
rélevabilité
sans aucune
transparence
où plusieurs
sont en train
de s'enrichir
et d'émener
une vie
extravagante
en exploitant
la foi
du peuple
des dieux
par contre
dans une réaction
complètement opposée
on a développé
une espèce
de mentalité
et des
missiologies
qui
aussi
susceptible
à haute
déviation
de l'enfer
de Satan
cherche
à réduire
à la misère
la vie
des ministres
plusieurs ministres
qui devraient être honorés
tels que la Bible
nous enseigne
reçoivent
un traitement
très misérable
et à plusieurs reprises
plusieurs
vivent
en burn out
beaucoup de crise
à cause
d'un mauvais
traitement
dont ils reçoivent
de l'église
lorsqu'ils
devraient recevoir
un autre type
de traitement
et donc c'est important
de remarquer
ces crises
dans notre passage
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer aussi
car
je pense que
ces textes
nous montrent
de manière très légitime
Paul Léantran
il y a plusieurs reprises
il les fait
donc ça ne caractérise
pas la majorité
de son ministère
mais à plusieurs reprises
il donne
des autobiographies
il donne des récits
il raconte
sa propre histoire
afin
d'illustrer
donc c'est intéressant
c'est pas pour
s'auto-promouvoir
mais c'est pour
attester sa fidélité
et se défendre
contre des accusations
des autres
et donc
il doit savoir
qu'il est dans une position
d'instruction
il ne peut pas
au nom
d'une espèce
de fausse humilité
cacher
des données
qu'il doit communiquer
pour que les choses
soient clairement
assimilées
et donc ici
nous avons une manière
très intéressante
Paul va évoquer
comme il fait
à Galate
des épisodes
autobiographiques
assez importants
par rapport
à ces choses
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer aussi
pour conclure
l'introduction
la liaison
entre les versets 9
ok
et ces passages
car au verset 9
l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de faire usage
de son modèle
pour servir
des répères
et du fait
que les philippiens
vont rendre compte
à Dieu
à cause du fait
qu'ils ont un modèle
de sainteté
devant eux
Dieu a choisi
de donner à cette église
comme guide spirituel
quelqu'un
qui menait
une vie belle
et fidèle
qui faisait beaucoup
de renoncements
pour l'évangile
et donc là
il pousse cette église
à marcher
quelque part
à la hauteur
des choses
qu'ils ont vues
dans l'incarnation
de l'évangile
dans la vie
de l'apôtre Paul
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
qu'à partir de là
il va faire beaucoup
d'éloges
à cette église
car au moins
dans cet aspect
les philippiens
ils manifestaient
une reconnaissance
très biblique
très légitime
une reconnaissance
qui plaît
les seigneurs
par rapport
à la manière
dont ils ont été généreux
et constamment généreux
envers l'apôtre Paul
donc il dit
j'ai éprouvé
une grande joie
dans les seigneurs
c'est que vous avez
pu enfin renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments
pour moi
vous y pensiez bien
mais l'occasion
vous manquait
donc quel est
l'objectif
de l'apôtre Paul ici
déjà il est en train
de dire
marchez comme moi-même
je marche
dans la sainteté
et les dieux de la paix
sera avec vous
mais en même temps
lorsqu'il dit
ce que vous avez appris
des mois
ce que vous avez reçu
et entendu des mois
l'apôtre Paul
il est conscient aussi
que s'il y a
une église
qui a conscience
du fait
qu'ils ont beaucoup reçu
et c'est une question
de justice
de présenter à Paul
un retour
voilà pourquoi
il revient
au verset
au verset 13
au verset 14
cependant vous avez bien fait
de prendre part
à ma détresse
vous les savez vous-même
philippien
au commencement
de la préservation
lorsque j'ai parti
de la macédone
aucune église
n'entra en compte
avec moi
pour ce qu'elle donnait
et recevait
donc vous voyez
la relation
tout comme les seigneurs
Jésus-Christ l'a dit
que c'est lui
les seigneurs ont ordonné
qui prêche l'évangile
qu'il vit de l'évangile
donc c'est une question
des droits
c'est une question
des justices
des rémunérations
donc quelque part
Paul était conscient
qu'il avait
beaucoup donné
aux philippiens
et que les philippiens
avaient reçu
beaucoup de la part
de l'apôtre Paul
des dieux
à travers Paul
et voilà pourquoi
la manière
dont les philippiens
sont en train d'agir
envers l'apôtre Paul
est aussi une question
des retours
par rapport aux choses
qu'ils ont reçues
c'est clair pour vous ?
donc on est bon
par rapport à l'introduction
on va rentrer dans les textes
donc dans les seigneurs
les royaumes des dieux
pendant notre pèlerinage
nous avons pour source
des joies
les soins affectueux
ou la reconnaissance généreuse
envers les ministres
de l'évangile
c'est la joie
qui retrouve
les ministres
c'est la joie
qui retrouve aussi
le peuple des dieux
et donc remarquons bien
d'abord les premiers aspects
de cette joie
c'est la joie
de recevoir
l'amour soigneux
verset 10
j'ai éprouvé
une grande joie
dans les seigneurs
de ceux qui vous avaient pu
enfin renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments
pour moi
vous y pensiez bien
mais l'occasion vous manquait
donc la première chose
qu'on remarque ici
c'est la joie
de l'apôtre Paul
de recevoir les soins
du seigneur
par son église
il dit
j'ai éprouvé
une grande joie
dans les seigneurs
donc la première chose
qu'il faut assimiler
c'est que notre seigneur
les dieux tout puissants
il a décidé
de prendre soin
de ses ministres
les promesses du Christ
par rapport à la manière
dont il prend soin
de ses ministres
elles sont récourantes
et elles sont
véritablement généreuses
par contre
les seigneurs
peuvent les faire
de manière directe
surprenante
miraculeuse
cette personne
va vivre
et dépendre
des dieux
par la foi
tous les temps
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
qu'ici
les seigneurs
lui-même
est en train
de pourvoir
à son ministre
à travers son église
remarquez
j'ai éprouvé
une grande joie
dans les seigneurs
de ceux que vous avez
pu enfin renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments
pour moi
et là
Paul
il est en train
de dire
ma joie
est trouvée
dans les seigneurs
car les seigneurs
a pourvu
à mes besoins
à travers vos vies
Christ
la tête
exerce son influence
envers son corps
et les bras
du Christ
étendus
pour pouvoir
aux besoins
de l'apôtre Paul
ce sont les bras
de l'église
des Philippiens
ce sont les contributions
les poches
des Philippiens
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que cette joie
de l'apôtre Paul
est une joie
enracinée
dans les seigneurs
mais qu'elle est
une joie
véritablement profonde
non car
il est accroché
au bien
qu'il reçoit
mais il est accroché
à ce qui
ses dons
représentent
attention
vous avez pu
renouveler
vos contributions
financières
envers moi
vous avez pu
renouveler quoi
l'expression
de vos
sentiments
pour moi
donc comment
les Philippiens
en prenant
en considération
les caractéristiques
actuelles
de la vie
de l'apôtre Paul
pouvaient
les mieux
exprimer
leur amour
pour Paul
est exprimé
par la provision
généreuse
des biens
qui peuvent
soulager
ses misères
sa détresse
lorsqu'il est
en prison
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
la provision
des biens
sont une expression
d'amour
c'est la relation
authentique
d'amour
entre les Philippiens
qui ont beaucoup
reçu de l'apôtre Paul
et qui veulent
donner à l'apôtre Paul
l'expression
aussi de leur amour
pour lui
donc la provision
des biens
est une expression
d'amour
voilà pourquoi
la joie
elle est bien
enracinée ici
la constance
de cet amour
est aussi
remarquée
dans
ses versets
donc l'apôtre Paul
il est davantage
dans la joie
car
ce n'est pas
la première fois
que les Philippiens
sont en train
de vouloir
avec beaucoup d'efforts
faire arriver
chez Paul
l'expression
de leur sentiment
c'est à dire
la générosité
ou la provision
donc ils veulent
que l'apôtre Paul
reçoive un bon traitement
et ils le veulent
de manière constante
donc des fois
malheureusement
à cause du fait
que nous sommes
des êtres
très inconstants
et que nous avons
cette tendance
et même les flèches
des satan
qui sont gentilles
dans la tête
des doutés
si les personnes
qu'un jour
nous ont apprécié
ou ont apprécié
ce que Dieu a fait
dans leur vie
à travers nos vies
ils continuent
d'apprécier
et c'est intéressant
c'est de remarquer
que quelque part
les plus matures
est une église
un ministère
des personnes
qui contribuent
à notre ministère
les plus on l'apprécie
c'est pas à la proportion
du montant
qu'ils puissent nous donner
c'est à la proportion
de leur chrétienté
de leur piété
et c'est intéressant
car c'est une confirmation
du Christ
envers notre ministère
et si jamais
à un moment donné
on arrête
de recevoir
ces supports
on se demande
est-ce qu'on a fait
quelque chose de mauvais
est-ce qu'ils nous ont abandonné
est-ce qu'ils se sont déviés
de leur foi
et ça c'est intéressant
la joie de l'apôtre Paul
c'est car
même si
les philippiens
n'ont pas toujours
pu contribuer
avec les ministères
de l'apôtre Paul
ils ont toujours voulu
donc là c'est intéressant
renouvelez
l'expression
de vos sentiments
pour moi
vous y pensez bien
mais l'occasion
vous manquait
donc c'est intéressant
l'occasion vous manquait
pourquoi
Paul était possiblement
inaccessible
lorsqu'il était en voyage
tous les temps
c'était difficile
de les trouver peut-être
maintenant il est emprisonné
ça lui donne l'occasion
peut-être de se reposer un peu
de recevoir quelques soins
pour plus misérable
soit sa vie
à la prison
mais en réalité
c'est que Paul là
il était accessible
il était
comment on peut dire
traçable
peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas
pu donner à Paul
car d'autres églises
sont parvenues
à ses besoins
et donc il n'avait pas
besoin pendant cet instant
il n'y manquait
plus de ressources
c'est possible aussi
peut-être qu'eux-mêmes
les philippiens
manquaient de ressources
pendant ces ans
même s'ils voulaient
continuer d'offrir
quoi que c'est
la moins probable
des raisons
car
les philippiens
dès le départ
n'avaient pas beaucoup
de ressources
et ils ont toujours aidé
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que cette constance
de l'amour
des philippiens
envers l'apôtre Paul
était une source
constante
aussi
des joies
pour les ministres
savoir
qu'il n'était pas
abandonné par Christ
car son église
son corps
était en train
de continuer
de vouloir
et de renouveler
ses soins
envers lui
ce qui est malheureusement
très rare
dans la culture
plus récente
qui s'est développée
dans l'église
par rapport aux ministres
c'est que
c'est rare
de trouver
des ministres
de l'évangile
dont l'église
s'anticipe
à leurs besoins
malheureusement
on trouve très peu
des philippiens
entre nous aujourd'hui
et comme j'ai dit
parfois c'est
à cause d'une réaction
extrême
aux abus
à cet égard
à la théologie
de la prospérité
à cause
des méfiances
à cause tout simplement
du péché
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment
on voit comment
les hommes des dieux
surtout ceux qui commencent
un nouveau travail
doivent transpirer
énormément
et doivent frapper
toujours à la porte
pour solliciter de l'aide
je me rappelle
les premières années
des ministères ici
quand on rentrait au Brésil
j'avais à peine le temps
de me reposer
pour les vacances
car je devrais faire
les tours des églises
en démontrant
les besoins
pour chercher
de l'aide
les secours
et donc malheureusement
ce n'est pas comme ça
que l'église
devrait marcher
mais nous devons
embrasser
cet appel
et ces modèles
des philippiens
à cet égard
s'anticiper
être régulier
avoir les sentiments
savoir
que nous participons
de la même cause
et donc c'est intéressant
Christ
et avec Paul
par l'église
l'église
est entrée
en prison
avec l'apôtre Paul
et il était
par la personne
des patrodites
embrassé
par toute l'église
des philippiens
et il a eu
le réconfort
et la joie
de recevoir
cet amour soigneux
donc les premiers aspects
c'est cet amour soigneux
que l'église
des philippiens
pourvoie à l'apôtre Paul
c'est la joie
du ministre
mais ce qui est intéressant
dans cette relation d'amour
comme dans toute relation
légitime d'amour
c'est que lorsque
la personne
qui nous aimons
assimile
notre amour
nous sommes aussi
dans la joie
quand on voit
que la personne
a produit
la joie
et les plaisirs
dans la personne
qu'on admire
qu'on aime
qu'on veut
manifester nos sentiments
ça fait aussi
que notre joie
augmente
donc là
on peut parler aussi
de la joie
des philippiens
d'avoir plus
un ministre bien-aimé
un ministre digne
de l'évangile
et donc là
l'apôtre Paul
c'est intéressant
comment
il va assimiler
la contribution
des philippiens
car il dit
regardez bien
la joie
de l'apôtre Paul
n'était pas
citant
dans les biens
qu'il a reçus
et regardez bien
de ceux
qui vous avaient
pu enfin
renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments
vers moi
vous êtes avec moi
vous percevez
ce qu'il est en train
de dire
c'est que
les philippiens
étaient en train
de goûter
une détresse
la détresse
de vouloir aider
et de ne pas trouver
comment
la détresse
de voir
un homme
des dieux
bien-aimés
qui méritait
être secourus
et qui n'avait
pas trouvé
des moyens
pour parvenir
à ses besoins
donc il dit
je suis content
j'ai goûté
une grande joie
dans le Seigneur
car maintenant
vous avez
retrouvé
la joie
de pouvoir
rénover
envers nous
ou envers moi
l'expression
de vos sentiments
vous aviez été
empêché
de manifester
votre amour
envers moi
vous devriez être
en train de prier
peut-être en train
de considérer
combien triste
était ma situation
en prison
vous voudrez tellement
qu'au moins
vos paroles
arrivent dans mes oreilles
pour que j'écoute
on est avec toi
on prie pour toi
voici les soulagements
qu'on apporte
et l'apôtre Paul
il sait très bien
que cette église
pouvait maintenant
se réjouir
car leur soutien
leur expression
d'amour
est arrivée
à l'apôtre Paul
donc c'est la joie
de produire
la joie
d'un ministre
bien-aimé
surtout
lorsqu'il se trouve
dans des détresses
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
car la joie
de la moindre contribution
n'est pas proportionnelle
aux ressources reçues
comme Jésus a fait l'éloge
de la pauvre veuve
mais du désir
avec joie
de contribuer
avec les remdes des dieux
et donc quand on va
à la piété
et là
pour faire osage
d'illustration personnelle
je me rappelle très bien
comment
dans les débuts
de notre ministère ici
quand on faisait
ces visites d'église
c'était intéressant
de remarquer
que dans la plupart des temps
les églises
qui donnaient les plus
c'était les églises
les moins riches
et on voyait
la joie
et ça apportait aussi
un sentiment
d'écrante énorme
de rendre compte
devant Dieu
de la générosité
de ces églises
mais combien leur piété
était davantage évidente
par leur générosité
dans leur détresse
et comment cela signifiait
pour nous
attention
la confirmation
des dieux
pour notre ministère
ce n'était pas
si tant
que toutes
les demandes
étaient remplies
mais que la moindre
manifestation
d'un sacrifice
d'amour
envers les rois hommes
était la confirmation
des dieux
pour nous
qu'il était avec nous
et donc remarquez bien
l'apôtre Paul
n'avait pas forcément
besoin
il les dira bientôt
des ressources
de cette église
mais la manière
dont cette église
est généreuse
et régulière
envers lui
ça fait sa joie
et c'est la joie
aussi de cette église
de savoir
qu'ils peuvent représenter
pour ses ministres
bien aimés
l'encouragement
des dieux
dont il a besoin
dans un temps
si difficile
vous avez
pu enfin
rénover l'expression
de vos sentiments
pour moi
Paul assimilait
l'angoisse
de cette église
d'être privée
surtout car
cette église
savait possiblement
qu'elle était
l'une des seules
églises régulières
dans les mantis
de la pauvre
Paul
donc aux missions
de manière générale
nous devons participer
mais il y a
une joie
particulière
lorsque nous
pouvons
contribuer
avec un ministre
bien aimé
c'est-à-dire
remplir
les silhouettes
c'est intéressant
de faire des dons
pour les hommes
des dieux
et c'est
quelque part
sécurisé
de faire des dons
des dieux
envers des ministères
qui sont déjà
établis
mais c'est intéressant
surtout
de développer
des liens
intimes
avec les ministres
de l'évangile
qu'on puisse
apprécier
leur ministère
avec qui on puisse
avoir
des vrais liens
d'affection
voilà pourquoi
on a appris
dès le départ
même lorsque
on est devant
à nouveau
quelqu'un
qui n'est pas
très riche
qui est peu
peut-être
mais qui veut
contribuer
et on est tenté
parfois à dire
on n'a pas besoin
et ça
ça peut être
une humiliation
pour la personne
et plus que ça
c'est une manière
d'empêcher
cette personne
d'égouter
la joie
d'être
la provision
des dieux
peu importe
combien elle donne
la joie
d'être
la provision
des dieux
pour ses ministres
donc c'est la joie
de plaire
un ministre
bien aimé
c'est la joie
de participer
on n'a jamais
l'opportunité
de ne pas participer
aux missions
nous devons
surtout
au moins prier
nous pouvons
aller
mais il faut toujours
que quelqu'un
soutienne la corde
pour qu'on descende
les puits
des missions
donc là
il goûtait
la joie
de contribuer
je me rappelle
très bien
dans les premières
fois où j'ai prêché
Dieu dans sa grâce
m'a donné l'opportunité
de prêcher beaucoup
et de faire des travaux
un peu missionnaires
dans les airs
les plus pauvres
de ma ville
à Rio
dans les favelas
j'y voyais
de manière très belle
la manière dont
il cherchait toujours
à être généreux
envers nous
je me rappelle
que les premiers dons
c'était un très bon repas
qu'on a reçu
des choses très simples
mais c'est cette hospitalité
qui représente aussi
la manière dont Dieu
pourvoit
et confirme
et donc c'est très beau
de voir la manière
dont les Philippiens
ils goûtaient cette joie
de pouvoir être généreux
et de savoir
qu'ils ont plu
imaginez-vous
la manière dont
les Philippiens
reçoivent cette lettre
et qu'ils imaginent
que l'apôtre Paul
est en pleine détresse
et qu'il dit
j'ai éprouvé une grande joie
dans le Seigneur
car vous avez pu
renouveler l'expression
de votre sentiment
vers moi
et troisième aspect
c'est que
nous remarquons ici
la joie
du contentement chrétien
donc
cette discussion
cette offrande
que les Philippiens
ont apporté
à Paul
dans sa prison
a permis
qu'on reçoive
cet enregistrement
biblique
qu'il nous porte
l'un des enseignements
les plus glorieux
qu'on trouve dans les Écritures
donc c'est très intéressant
car
Paul
il veut exprimer
sa reconnaissance
mais il ne veut pas
que cette Église
pense qu'il a vraiment
besoin de l'argent
ce n'est pas à cause
de l'argent
qu'il est en train
d'écrire
ou exprimer
sa reconnaissance
c'est une question
d'amour
et en même temps
en participant
plus proche
de la vie
de l'apôtre
Paul
de la manière
correcte
comme il faut
cette Église
avait aussi
les privilèges
de contempler
des plus proches
de s'asseoir
dans les premiers rangs
du cinéma
de la vie
d'un des hommes
les plus soignés
par Christ
et donc
cette Église
qui participe
des proches
de la vie
d'un ministre fidèle
elle apprend
la manière
dont Dieu
pourvoit
la satisfaction
et les contentements
dans toutes les phases
ou dans toutes les circonstances
de sa vie
et voilà pourquoi
c'est important
lorsqu'on est
devant l'homme
des dieux
véritablement compris
mais par Dieu
de chercher
à connaître
son historique
car si quelqu'un
arrive
dans la lecture
de l'histoire
de David
ou de Joseph
dans la moitié
ils vont rater
l'école
de l'illumination
qui a traversé
Joseph et David
ils vont penser
que David
a toujours habité
dans un palais
ou que Joseph
a toujours eu
la puissance
de régir
toute l'Egypte
donc c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
comment l'apôtre Paul
ici
il nous présente
cette symétrie glorieuse
de la manière
dont le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
pourvoit
la manière
dont le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
pourvoit
les contentements
donc regardez
l'école
de contentement
telle qu'on voit
ici
nous pouvons
attention
trouver la joie
du contentement
chrétien
lorsqu'on apprend
l'enseignement
biblique
à propos
du soutien
des ministres
car Christ
est celui
qui traite
directement
avec son Église
avec son ministre
parfois
il est fait
à travers
les moyens
d'Église
parfois
il est fait
d'autres manières
et même
lorsqu'il trouve
ou que les ministres
ils trouvent
dans les voies
de la souffrance
de la privation
là il trouvera
aussi
quelque chose
qui ni l'Église
ni tous les biens
au monde
peuvent pourvoir
la joie
de cette force
d'endurance
qui Christ pourvoit
l'intimité
avec Christ
qui va marcher
pour nous tous
mais qui d'habitude
sont particulièrement
notées
dans la vie
des hommes
des dieux
voilà pourquoi
nous ne pouvons
jamais assumer
que la spiritualité
soit donnée
dans la même mesure
à toutes les personnes
car la spiritualité
est intermêlée
avec les expériences
des vies
qu'on a
avec les seigneurs
et les expériences
des vies
qu'on a
avec les seigneurs
forment une école
d'apprentissage
qui peut nous rendre
plus sensibles
à certaines circonstances
qu'il y a d'autres
noms
pour qu'en nous
la sensibilité
par exemple
des poids chers
lorsqu'ils prêchaient
dans notre conférence
on pourrait se demander
mais pourquoi
on n'a pas tous
ressenti
ce qu'il a ressenti
peut-être
car on n'a pas
tous
le même
degré
de scolarité
dans l'école
de la spiritualité
la même sensibilité
!
et ici
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
la puissance
de ces versets
donc nous apprenons
cette école
de contentement
et pourquoi
j'ai mis l'emphase
sur le fait
d'apprendre
et d'école
car ce n'est pas
quelque chose
qu'on puisse connaître
par la théorie biblique
tout simplement
regardez le texte
ce n'est pas
en vue
de mes besoins
que j'ai dit
c'est là
car j'ai appris
à être content
de l'état
où je me trouve
donc la première chose
à saisir
c'est que
le contentement
et la satisfaction
c'est
la joie
d'un ordre
qui surmonte
les circonstances
vous êtes avec moi?
ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne souffre pas
qu'on ne passe pas
par des tristesses
mais en traversant
la tristesse
nous pouvons quand même
expérimenter
une joie
d'un ordre supérieur
car
en ayant traversé
déjà avec les seigneurs
plusieurs tristesses
dans les passés
on a pu constater
qu'il n'a jamais manqué
qu'il donne toujours
la capacité d'endurer
qu'il sera toujours là
c'était par ces détresses
qu'on était poussé
à chercher plus sa face
son refuge
et qu'on a développé
ou qu'on a développé
une sensibilité
pour réjouir plus
de sa présence
donc c'est la vraie joie
avec les lots
décidés
pour les seigneurs
pour ma vie
aujourd'hui
donc si Dieu
si les seigneurs
ont décidé
qu'aujourd'hui
dans ma vie
je devais vivre
ce que je suis en train
de vivre
ça ne va pas
m'empêcher
de chercher
les moyens légitimes
pour m'en sortir
mais ça ne va pas
produire en moi
l'inquiétude
l'anxiété
ça ne va pas
voler la paix
qui se passe
sous ton intelligence
et la joie
qui est engracinée
dans le seigneur
qui m'a délivré
de l'enfer
et qui a déjà assuré
que je pars
vers l'éternité
dans la gloire
des joies suprêmes
et que je compte
avec sa présence
et que mon trésor
le plus précieux
c'est la piété
avec contentement
ici-bas
dans mon pèlerinage
j'ai accès à Dieu
à Christ
et je peux voir
Christ formé en moi
particulièrement
par cette détresse
spécifique
qu'il a décidée
pour moi
aujourd'hui
dans ma vie
donc il dit
le contentement
il est quelque part
quelque chose
d'au-dessus
des circonstances
car l'apôtre Paul
a appris
à être content
donc le contentement
c'est cette joie
avec les lots
décidés par Dieu
pour ces moments
spécifiques
de ma vie
aujourd'hui
mais c'est intéressant
car c'est une question
d'acquisition
et d'acquisition
expérimentale
à nouveau
c'est une école
il dit
à deux reprises
au verset 11
et au verset 12
il va dire
car j'ai appris
à être content
de l'état
où je me trouve
et au verset 12
en tout
et partout
j'ai appris
donc tout ce qui m'arrive
c'est une manière
que Dieu utilise
pour m'apprendre
surtout
si je suis résolu
à persévérer
il ne faut pas déconnecter
persévérer dans les schémas
des sanctités
de ne pas compromettre
l'évangile
je serai fidèle
j'aurai l'impression
que toutes les portes
se ferment contre moi
mais Dieu ouvrira
une sortie
où Dieu va soutenir
ma vie
et même si on meurt
on part vers la gloire
jamais réunis l'évangile
et donc il dit
j'ai appris
tous m'ont abandonné
c'est ce qu'il a dit
dans ma première défense
mais le Seigneur
m'a soutenu
pour que je prêche
l'évangile
avec hardiesse
devant les autorités
donc ici c'est intéressant
dans cette école
expérimentale de Paul
il est devenu un docteur
il dit
quand il dit
j'essaie de vivre
il est en train de parler
de son dégré actuel
de son diplôme
quelque part
aujourd'hui
j'essaie de vivre
dans toutes circonstances
j'ai déjà traversé
des moments
où j'étais dans des conditions
très aisées
j'ai déjà traversé
des moments
où la privation
était extrême
et la seule constance
que j'ai perçue
dans cette vie
c'est que le Seigneur
ne m'a jamais manqué
et la joie
était toujours accessible
et la paix
j'essaie de vivre
c'est la maîtrise
actuelle
de la peau trépaule
je sais vivre
dans l'humiliation
dans l'abondance
en tout et partout
j'ai appris
et ici c'est
son parcours
de scolarité
lorsqu'il vous lisez
d'autres portions
de son autobiographie
lorsqu'il parle
de tous les coups de feu
qu'il a reçus
de toutes les misères
qu'il a traversées
de toutes les persécutions
et il répond
en tout et partout
j'ai appris
à être rassasiés
et à avoir fond
être dans l'abondance
être dans la disette
et le problème
c'est qu'à nouveau
ici nous sommes devant
d'un côté
l'implosion
de la théologie
de la prospérité
qui veulent nous convaincre
que la volonté
des dieux
c'est qu'un homme des dieux
soit toujours entouré
des gloires
et d'extravagances terrestres
et là
c'est complètement implosé
ces châteaux de sable
et de l'autre côté
c'est complètement explosé
aussi la missiologie
de la misère
les pensées
qu'il faut traiter
toujours
que ça soit
notre responsabilité
de maintenir
l'homme des dieux
humble
c'est à nous
d'obliger
qu'il vit toujours
par la foi
sauf qu'il fait partie
de la foi
les promesses du Christ
par exemple
qu'il reçoit encore
dans cette vie
s'il a rénoncé
des familles
des biens
sa terre
cent fois plus encore
dans cette vie
et encore plus
dans la vie éternelle
où nous sommes
en train
d'harmoniser
les traitements
qu'on doit rendre
à un homme des dieux
aux priorités bibliques
qu'est-ce qui c'est
à nous de faire
à eux
de manifester
pour confirmer
qu'ils sont
des vrais ministres
appelés des dieux
et donc c'est intéressant
car Paul avait
pour fondement
de son contentement
les seigneurs
Jésus Christ
et c'est 13
l'un des versets
les plus
abusés
dans les présents
j'ai pu tout
par celui
qui me fortifie
et des personnes
nous encouragent
à faire
des prières
très idolâtres
qui rassemblent
plus
à la pensée
positiviste
des ésotérites
de nos jours
c'est l'ésotérisme
gospel
en nous amenant
à déclarer
des choses
ou décréter
en imposant
nos désirs
idolâtres
pour que Dieu
sponsorise
nos désirs
charnais
temporels
Seigneur
je déclare
tu m'as fait tête
et non que
et ça part
dans toutes les directions
j'ai pu tout
passer
avec mes
fortifiques
c'est à dire
j'ai appris
à être content
dans la misère
j'ai appris
à être content
dans la disette
dans la famine
car
il pourvoit
la force
pour endurer
il pourvoit
la force
pour rester fidèle
sous toute menace
et donc
ce que l'apôtre
Paul
est en train
de dire
c'est qu'il
voit sa vie
par la perspective
d'un seigneur
les seigneurs
du cosmos
c'est lui
qui soutient
tout l'univers
par sa parole
puissante
c'est lui
qui avait promis
qu'il allait
pourvoir
à ses ministres
c'est celui
qui
envers qui
toutes les atomes
disent amen
le coeur
du persécuteur
est dans sa mort
aucune autorité
a été donnée
à Pilate
qui ne soit pas
accordée par Christ
par Dieu lui-même
vous comprenez
et donc l'apôtre Paul
il sait
que peu importe
quelle est la situation
qu'il vit
c'est le seigneur Jésus
qui est là
et il pourvoit
toutes ces expériences
de vie passée
attestent cette réalité
quand il va
raconter son témoignage
en Galates chapitre 1
il va dire
vous avez connu
quel était mon comportement
lorsque j'ai persécuté
l'église
et comment j'étais
une étoile montante
vis-à-vis
à ceux qui étaient
de mon métier
dans le judaïsme
j'étais une pensée
brillante
donc il a su
attention
dans sa vie passée
avant la conversion
Christ était déjà
en train de les préparer
pour être un ministre
de l'évangile
et dans sa vie passée
c'est clair que l'apôtre Paul
l'a réjoui
de beaucoup d'abondance
les meilleures écoles
les meilleures études
double nationalité
dans l'empire romant
il pouvait faire
usage même
des bonnes choses
qu'il avait
des privilèges
et qui ont été
très perspicaces
pour l'évangile
mais il a aussi passé
pour plein
des privations
et même
les atrocités
qu'il a commises
en persécutant
l'église
ont joué
un rôle incroyable
pour qu'il
rebondisse
par la grâce
avec ses désirs
quelque part
de compenser
ce qu'il avait fait
pour devenir
les plus grands
missionnaires
théologiens
l'homme
le plus
reconnaissant
vers la grâce
des dieux
qu'il a sauvé
qu'il a pardonné
toutes les difficultés
qu'il a traversées
toutes les bonnes choses
qu'il a réjouies
avant la conversion
et après la conversion
c'est la même chose
le texte
il est clair
il a appris
à être content
lorsqu'il était
dans l'abondance
mais aussi
lorsqu'il traversait
la difficulté
donc il y a
une partie
de l'école
de contentement
qui nous vient
par les privations
ici il mentionne
l'humiliation
la famine
et la disette
ce sont des termes
littérales
des choses
qu'il a traversées
d'habitude
Dieu
humilie
ses ministres
c'est pas une règle
générale
qui va valoir
pour tous
ou au moins
pas dans les mêmes
aspects
et ils seront
tous humiliés
par Dieu
et quelque part
les plus vite
ils traversent
ces humiliations
les mieux
car c'est une voie
par laquelle
Dieu veut surtout
attester à ces hommes
qui par leur fidélité
challenge
privation
et difficulté
les Christ lui-même
est là
il assure
leur réussite
s'ils persévèrent
dans un chaînement
des fidélités
les fruits peuvent
prendre longtemps
à paraître
mais il n'y a pas
une autre voie
à marcher
que ce soit
pas la voie
de la fidélité
Christ est là
il suffit
comme pour Jérémie
pendant tout son ministère
et si Dieu
dans sa grâce
plus tard
selon son bon plaisir
et sa sagesse
veut honorer
les ministères
de ses ministres
par des bonnes saisons
par la contemplation
des fruits
tant mieux
sauf qu'à partir
de là
il aura
moins de risques
d'échanger
les droits
d'hénais
par un plat
et lentilles
car nous pouvons
nous perdre
dans l'abondance
tout comme nous pouvons
nous perdre
dans la disette
et donc à la fin
des comptes
ces hommes
qui ont été
entraînés
à tout toucher
légèrement
ce sont des hommes
qui ont passé
par des privations
où ils n'avaient
qu'Christ
et Christ était
tout pour eux
et les jours
où ils auront
quelque chose
ça ne sera rien
comparativement
à Christ
ils vont considérer
comme dit l'apôtre
chapitre 3
tout comme des labours
pour gagner Christ
c'est une école
qui détruit
l'idolâtrie de l'argent
du confort
de bien-être
de l'assurance
des vies
des préconditions
pour travailler
pour se donner
au ministère
qui détruit
la professionnalisation
du ministère
sacré
qui conduit
un homme
à ne pas dépendre
de l'institution
ou du bon état
de l'église
une école
qui promeut
les rois
des dieux
malgré tout
une école
qui ne relâche pas
devant les difficultés
culturelles
politiques
c'est une école
qui ne cherche pas
à adapter
les goûts
du scandale
de l'évangile
au palais
du peuple
politiquement correct
qui est l'homme
qui peut déclarer
ce que la Bible
déclare
sans hésitation
c'est un homme
qui craint plus
la proximité
avec Christ
que toutes les puissances
terrestres
c'est pas une question
d'être les plus courageux
c'est savoir
à qui on doit
craindre les plus
les Christ puissants
ou les autorités
éphémères
c'est une école
qui ne dépend pas
de l'état
des maturités
ou des corruptions
d'une église
c'est une école
des fois
une école
des prises
des risques
une école
qui embrasse
les vulnérabilités
du ministère
une école
qui nécessite
à checker
les priorités
d'horreur
et si c'est ça
la priorité
d'horreur
je me lance
si Christ a dit
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
même si les autorités
temporelles
se manifestent
à l'opposé
on sait
qu'ils ne peuvent pas
résister
à celui qui a promis
qu'il allait bâtir
son église
comment arrêter
un homme qui dit
comme l'apôtre dit
au chapitre 20
d'Actes
verset 24
mais je n'ai fait
pour moi-même
aucun cas de ma vie
quelle menace
peut freiner
un homme
qui ne fait plus
aucun cas de sa vie
comme si elle
m'était précieuse
pourvu que j'accomplisse
ma course avec joie
et les ministères
que j'ai reçus
du Seigneur
d'annoncer
la bonne nouvelle
de la grâce
des dieux
qui peut freiner
un tel homme
verset 20
du chapitre
nous a dit
selon ma ferme attente
et mon espérance
que je ne serai
point confus
en riant
mais que maintenant
comme toujours
Christ sera glorifié
dans mon corps
avec une pleine assurance
soit par ma vie
soit par ma mort
car Christ est ma vie
et la mort m'est un gant
mais s'il est utile
pour moi
et pour mon oeuvre
pardon
que je vive dans la chair
je ne saurais dire
ce que je dois préférer
je suis pressé
des deux côtés
j'ai le désir
de m'en aller
et d'être avec Christ
ce qui est beaucoup
de beaucoup
elle est mieux
mais à cause de vous
il est plus nécessaire
que je demeure
dans la chair
cet homme persévère
cet homme
a pour but
les ministères
avancer les rangs
des dieux
il a déjà tout gagné
il n'a plus rien à perdre
c'est l'école du contentement
par les privations
qui nous trouvons partout
dans la Bible
dans la vie de David
de Joseph
de Moïse
c'est l'école du contentement
par les privations
qui nous trouvons
dans l'histoire de l'église
dans les premiers siècles
sous persécution
dans la période
de la réforme
avec la vraie église française
réformée
les vrais repères
pour nous
leur bataille
leur privation
Calvin
avait une école
qui a été connue
une école des pasteurs
qui était connue
l'école de la mort
de Jean Calvin
les personnes partaient
vers Genève
pour chercher réfuges
!
et ce qu'ils trouvaient
à Genève
c'était un homme
dans le même esprit
de l'apôtre Paul
qui encourageait
ces personnes
à revenir
au terrain missionnaire
et plusieurs
ont perdu leur vie
ont déversé leur sang
pour faire avancer
les rois hommes
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
dans ces passages
que Paul a aussi
appris à vivre
dans l'abondance
il y a
l'école de contentement
par la souffrance
tout comme il y a
l'école de contentement
par l'abondance
ce n'est pas en vue
de mes besoins
que je dis
c'est là
car j'ai appris
à être content
de l'état
où je me trouve
j'essaie de vivre
dans l'humiliation
dans l'abondance
en tout et partout
j'ai appris
à être rassasié
et avoir fond
à être dans l'abondance
et à être dans la disette
je puis tout
par celui
qui me fortifie
et donc
nous devons apprendre
à être dans l'abondance
car l'apôtre Paul
a pu réjouir
des bonnes choses
ici il dit
qu'il est dans l'abondance
avec les choses
qu'il a reçues
on peut considérer
que dans sa vie
et dans son ministère
lorsqu'il n'était pas
en train de s'exposer
aux persécutions
il recevait quand même
un bon traitement
particulièrement
des églises
qui savaient les chérir
on pense
au Seigneur Jésus Christ
qui ne s'est pas empêché
lui-même
de réjouir
des bonnes choses
de cette vie
qui participait
à certaines fêtes
lorsqu'il était dans la chair
et nous savons surtout
que le Seigneur Jésus Christ
s'est réjoui
des bonnes choses
qu'il lui-même
il a créé
et qu'il a toujours
réjoui des bonnes choses
car il est sorti
de la béatitude éternelle
pour venir nous sauver
et là on n'est pas
en train de parler
forcément des biens temporels
ou d'extravagances
mais quand on voit
la description extravagante
de la gloire céleste
de la restauration
nous savons
que Jésus n'aura pas
de problème
à réjouir des bonnes choses
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que même les simples choses
de la vie
qu'il pouvait
restaurer
son ministère
les marches
au bord de la mer
pour pouvoir prier
sous les montagnes
sous les oliviers
les bons repas
nous voyons
qu'il a les bonnes choses
de cette vie
qu'on ne doit pas priver
les hommes des dieux
on peut penser même
à Jean-Baptiste
qui à cause
de sa fidélité
a trouvé
une telle influence
qu'il a pu même
s'approcher
des autorités
des gouverneurs
et même s'il a fini
mort par la persécution
cela n'empêche pas
le fait
qu'il a pu
possiblement
et le plus probablement
réjouir aussi
des bonnes circonstances
et donc c'est intéressant
quand on voit
la vie de tous ces autres
hommes qu'on a considérés
qui est Dieu parfois
honore par sa grâce
un homme qui a traversé
beaucoup de souffrance
dans la fidélité
par la grâce
et la générosité
c'est intéressant
car nous devons apprendre
à être dans l'abondance
car il s'agit
d'apprendre
à tout toucher légèrement
l'appel missionnaire
l'appel d'un ministre
de tout laisser
pour se consacrer
au ministère
c'est un appel
très vulnérable
pour accomplir
une vocation
qui est comparée
à une vocation
militaire
d'une bataille
spirituelle
il va passer
par plein de privations
s'il va vraiment
vivre en vipieuse
il est toujours
vulnérable
par exemple
dans le jour
comme ça s'est passé
avec une famille
missionnaire
qu'on connaît
des pères
dans la garde
de leurs enfants
leurs cinq enfants
tout simplement
quand il est en train
de prêcher
la parole de Dieu
et éduquer
leurs enfants
selon la parole
de Dieu
tous ceux qui veulent
mêler en vipieuse
sont exposés
à cette vulnérabilité
cette difficulté
les persécutions
dont les circonstances
peuvent changer
de jour au lendemain
mais les pressions
continuelles
l'exposition
aux attaques
des satans
la préoccupation
avec toutes les églises
comme dit
l'apôtre Paul
et donc
quand on considère
l'importance
des périodes
de repos
des restaurations
des récréations
nous parlons
de manière très claire
comment nous devons
apprendre
je pense que
c'est
Toser
quelqu'un a été
un peu scandalisé
avec le fait
qu'il a pris
un passage
des trains
dans la
première classe
et les personnes
disaient
mais quelle gestion
des finances
etc
par contre
c'était un homme
qui vivait
en train de voyager
pour bénir
énormément de l'église
et qui devraient
prendre soin
de soi-même
afin de continuer
d'étudier
et d'ailleurs
l'un de ses ouvrages
les plus bénissants
qu'on trouve
jusqu'aujourd'hui
il était écrit
dans une allée
des trains
c'est là
où il a fait
tous ses livres
donc c'est intéressant
c'est pas pour
défendre
une administration
extravagante
mais c'est de savoir
reconnaître
les circonstances
qui peuvent
les mieux
projeter
les ministères
de certains
hommes de Dieu
dans des choses
qui soient légitimes
car on sait très bien
que Robert Murray
McShane
qui était un homme
avec un grand potentiel
pour l'évangile
il est mort à l'âge
des 28 ans
car il n'a pas pris
soin de lui-même
il a dit
Dieu m'a donné
un cheval
et un message
j'ai tué
les chevals
et là je ne peux plus
porter les messages
il parlait de son corps
de la manière
dont il s'est donné
quelque part
de manière responsable
c'est peut-être
Wesley qui a coigné
cette phrase
mais elle est très
souvent appliquée
à Robert Murray
McShane
et bien sûr
qu'il faut considérer
aussi
surtout ceux
qui ont de la famine
car dans la biographie
de plusieurs hommes
des dieux
qui ont beaucoup
fait pour les royaumes
à cause des exigences
qu'il y avait sur eux
pour continuer
de faire pousser
les ministères
pas mal d'entre eux
ont beaucoup
sacrifié leur famille
et donc l'église
elle doit apprendre
bien sûr
la générosité
des dieux
envers ses ministres
donc Paul est en train
de dire le suivant
par vous
aujourd'hui
Philippien
Dieu manifeste
sa générosité
envers moi
mais indépendamment
de votre participation
moi j'ai déjà goûté
à plusieurs reprises
les rafraîchissements
des dieux
la générosité
envers ma vie
à plusieurs reprises
j'ai vécu l'abondance
car Dieu a pourvu
de plusieurs manières
et d'autres manières
la vie d'un ministre
est similaire
à une vie militaire
où il doit apprendre
à toucher tout légèrement
car il ne sait pas
ce qui le demande
à temps de lui
et sa joie
n'est pas trouvée
dans ces choses
par contre
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que l'église
elle va apprendre
la générosité
par l'observation
dont Dieu prend soin
de manière
surprenante
des hommes
de Dieu
mais elle doit
participer aussi
des proches
afin
de représenter
quelque part
et s'accorder
à la générosité
du Christ lui-même
envers ses hommes
c'est la joie
d'être les bras
de Dieu
pour le soutien
de ses hommes
à nouveau
comme l'apôtre Paul
il dit
c'est lui qui a dit ça
aux riches
ordonne à ceux
qui sont riches
dans les siècles
présents
de ne pas être
haut d'esprit
ni de mettre
leur espérance
dans les richesses
en certaines
mais un Dieu
attention
qui nous fournit
abondément
toutes choses
pour que nous
en jouissons
et qu'est-ce qu'on trouve
plus tard
lorsqu'il dit
au verset 19
et mon Dieu
pourvoira
à tous vos besoins
juste un petit peu
au-dessus de la misère
quelle est la manière
des dieux
de nous traiter
Dieu pourvoira
à tous vos besoins
selon sa richesse
avec gloire
en Jésus Christ
avec quelle proportion
Dieu aimerait
que ses ministres
soient soignés
avec la proportion
dont le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
dit
cent fois
encore dans cette vie
et donc
il faut que l'Église
possiblement
dans notre jour
apprenne
plus
à chérir
et reproduire
l'école
de la réjouissance
des bonnes choses
pour qui
les ministres
servent avec la joie
tout en étant
assuré
par les bons témoignages
des vies
de cet homme
qui n'a jamais dépendu
de ces choses
et qui l'a toujours
persévéré fidèle
c'est l'école
du contentement
du Christ
c'est l'école
des hommes
qui sont satisfaits
en Christ
avec l'état
actuel des choses
et qui ont appris
avec Christ
à réjouir
de l'abondance
de la disette
car ce qu'il voit
dans ces circonstances
n'est pas forcément
les circonstances
qu'il voit
mais il voit la manière
dont les Christ
est en train
de faire son
réunir
avancer
et de conformer
leur caractère
au caractère
des dieux
c'est très important
de reconnaître
que dans cette sagesse
incroyable
des dieux
lorsque nous considérons
un job
ou un apôtre Paul
aucun argent
qui pourrait être offert
ne pouvait remplacer
l'école du contentement
ils n'échangeraient
rien
de leur souffrance
car
l'apprentissage
du contentement
en toutes circonstances
est infiniment supérieure
à toute valeur
qu'on puisse trouver
dans les bonnes choses
de cette vie
et nous allons considérer
plus sur ça
dans la prochaine fois
nous allons continuer
avec les prochains versets
la semaine prochaine
pour considérer
la symétrie
entre
d'un côté
Christ
pourvoi
et de l'autre côté
verset 14
cependant
vous avez bien fait
à prendre part
à ma détresse
d'un côté
un homme des dieux
qui dépend
exclusivement
de la provision
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
et de l'autre côté
une église
qui est responsable
pour représenter
les bras du Christ
dans la provision
de la provision
!